Dave ladies and gentlemen if I may say
sir I was enormous Lee touch to have
been asked to open the nightingale
hospital as part of a mass mobilization
to withstand the coronavirus crisis it
is without doubt a spectacular and
almost unbelievable feat of work in
every sense from its speed of
construction in just nine days as we've
heard to its size and the skills of
those who have created it an example if
everyone was needed of how the
impossible could be made possible and
how we can achieve the unthinkable
through human will and ingenuity the
creation of this hospital is above all
the results of an extraordinary
collaboration and partnership between
NHS managers the military and all those
involved to create a center on a scale
that has never been seen before in the
United Kingdom to convert one of the
largest national conference centres into
a field hospital
starting with 500 beds and with a
potential of 4,000 he's quite frankly
incredible now I was I was one of the
lucky ones to have kirby 19 relatively
mildly and if I may say so I'm so glad
to see the Secretary of State has also
recovered but for some it will be a much
harder a journey I am therefore so
relieved but everyone can now have the
reassurance that they will receive all
the necessary technical care they may
need and every chance to return to a
normal life this hospital therefore
offers us an intensely practical message
of hope for those who will need it most
at this time of national suffering that
is all
prey medicine gentlemen but it will be
required for as short a time and for as
few people as possible on behalf of the
nation I want to say a very big thank
you to the planners the builders the
Armed Forces
the generous companies and organizations
which have donated equipment and
services and all the support staff who
have made this possible all say we are
an immense debt of gratitude to the
doctors the nurses that technicians the
staff currently working in the health
service and those coming out of
retirement and the voluntary workers who
will be working within it and I can only
offer my special thoughts and prayers to
all those who will receive care within
it and let us hope less internal that it
will not be too long before this
terrible disease has left our land now I
need hardly say that the name of this
hospital could not have been more aptly
chosen Florence Nightingale the lady
with the lamp brought hope and healing
to thousands in their darkest hour in
this dark time this place will be a
shining light it is symbolic of the
selfless care and devoted service taking
place in innumerable settings with
countless individuals throughout the
United Kingdom there's and gentlemen as
the wonders of modern technology can
only do so much and I can't quite reach
that I could invite nightingales head of
Nursing Natalie gray on my behalf
to unveil the plaque to declare NHS
Nightingale Hospital open
[Applause]